i wanted to talk about this bitcoin
story uh we've got a quote here from
barons the biden administration is
preparing to release an executive action
that will task federal agencies with
regulating digital assets such as
bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies as a
matter of national security a person
familiar with the white house's plans
tell barons the national security
memorandum expected to come in the next
few weeks would task parts
of the government with analyzing digital
assets and assembling a regulatory
framework that covers cryptos stable
coins and nfts or non-fungible tokens
this person said the state department
treasury department national economic
council and council of economic advisors
would all be involved in the initiative
the white house national security
council would also be involved the
person said since crypto has economic
implications for national security along
those lines the administration would
instruct agencies to work on harmonizing
regulations of digital assets
between countries okay so we've talked a
little bit about bitcoin here actually
if you want just sort of bitcoin 101
i did an interview a few months back
with my friend and one of our locals
investors uh alex lloyd who wrote a book
he co-wrote a book called uh the little
bitcoin book i believe that's the title
and you can do a little more bitcoin 101
but in essence this idea of a
decentralized currency that no one the
fed nor any government is fully
controlling and it is traded between
people okay and then you can have you
know these nfts these digital assets
that you are trading between people this
is the biggest threat that exists really
to the sort of monolithic one state one
world government that seemingly wants to
lock us all in our rooms have us
strapped into vr headsets and you know
offer us a bunch of gruel to
occasionally eat out of as we uh play
whatever the hell it is that we're
playing on uh in the metaverse all day
long uh so this is this is should not be
surprising what i think is interesting
about it the reason i wanted to cover it
was because of the way it has sort of
creeped on us that bitcoin was and
crypto were these fringe things and then
it was like oh okay it's used in the
dark web or people are selling drugs on
it something like that then it starts
getting used then there are these
digital wallets and i've got a little
bit of crypto where you can trade when
it goes up and down you could trade it
like a stock and then you can take some
of your crypto money and you can
actually convert it say into a
mastercard and buy real products and it
was kind of good and then el salvador
said that they are going to start taking
cryptocurrency and then next thing you
know within a matter of just a couple
years it's a national security threat a
national security threat to the united
states and they're going to try to
figure out who's got bitcoin and how
they've got it and everything else so
there is a through line to today's show
from starting with breyer talking about
freedom
then going over to this truck convoy
these people who care about freedom and
then that there is a currency a new
digital currency that is trying to free
the people
i'm going to keep trying to free the
people i hope you will join me
you